i think i've came up with the largest  collection of old american cars in the  world  yeah all of them has a story  but they kindly take their place in the  forest you know and  they're part of the forest  they grew up partially in the forest  my name is walter dean lewis i run and  operate in on oak car city usa  i was born and raised in a junkyard and  i liked junkyards  this land was clear when i started  putting them in there  i wanted nature to take its course and  we just let it go wild  these cars come from other junkyards and  just individual people  and they all wind up here at oak car  city  ford chevrolet's general motors they  land out there in the forest  rotting away  we build things out of rust out there  and it is a piece of art  you